[Music]
your face may soon be the only thing you
need to board a flight imagine that some
airlines already testing facial
recognition technology with the federal
government the idea is to ditch boarding
passes the plan by Homeland Security
aims to increase the certainty of a
passenger's identity Kris Van Cleave is
at Logan International Airport in Boston
with a look at how the technology works
Chris good morning good morning JetBlue
flight 773 from Boston to Aruba is about
to take a test flight into the future
this machine is going to compare my
photo with a customs database to match
my passport it says I'm approved which
means I can board without my passport or
my boarding pass I'm just going straight
to Aruba so you can board without
presenting your boarding pass passport
or other travel documents this is a
trial of facial recognition technology
by US Customs and JetBlue the airline
wants to see if it makes the boarding
process faster I'm just gonna walk up
and they're gonna take a picture and
that's it it just amazes me the
technology the system matches images to
a government database of passport photos
a seamless process according to Joanna
Garrity from JetBlue customers are
stressed when they travel crew members
get stressed as well we're looking at
how do you reduce those friction points
how do you create an experience that
doesn't have any lines and a circle that
is revolutionary in the airline industry
and Delta's right at the front of it
hello oh yeah we were there as Delta's
senior vice president Gareth Joyce
tested a facial recognition bag drop at
Minneapolis Airport passengers will be
able to check luggage without an
employee verifying their identity the
airline is also testing facial
recognition at boarding gates in New
York and Atlanta you can literally go
from your curb to plane without having
to interact with a human being if you so
desire but even as the technology speeds
passengers through the airport couldn't
be faster
yeah pretty fast some fear it's moving
too fast implementation of the use of
biometrics need to be scrutinized very
closely Jeremy Scott from the Electronic
Privacy Information Center worries about
the use of personal identifiers that
cannot be changed as we consolidate
biometric data into big databases and we
use it more and more those databases
will become targets and the risk of data
breach increases greatly u.s. custom
says it's not using these devices to
store photos and privacy is a primary
concern for those long TSA lines of
checkpoints the TSA is now starting to
experiment with fingerprint verification
for identities Gail